how do we then introduce time how do we
do it any suggestions anyone recall what
direction we go in here excellent okay
so this guy here V right just like we
noticed over here era shouldn't rub that
office yet okay r v is the Exxon DT so
time doesn't look like it's here but it
really is ok so I'm going to say DX on
dt equals this ok by definition ok now
what am I trying to get to I'm trying to
make X the subject in terms of tea
that's that's good so far I've got lots
of teas I've got next there okay how do
I get there what should I do now I'm
going to have to clearly i'm going to
have to integrate somewhere right but i
can't integrate with this with respect
to time why can't i integrate with
respect to time it's not in terms of
time right but i can integrate with
respect to X right so that means this
guy needs to be on the bottom I'm trying
to explain why it's a lot of arbitrary
so we just flip this guy over the reason
we flip him is because we need to
integrate with respects to the
denominator ok so you flip the left that
means you flip the right okay all right
now I can integrate can integrate if i
integrate this side with respect to X
what happens you just get tired just get
time ok just like if you integrate it
into dy on the X with respect to X you
get y plus a constant of course ok so
the time of the day that's good now you
look at this guy and you think
now he's not a standard form he's not
but it's close enough to one that we can
work it out the question is how do you
how do you tease it out of there now
what do we know about this right because
this point is really important this is
the point in the exam where you're like
oh what do I do I'm rushed right what
things can you tell me about this that
are obvious what I'm trying to lead us
in a direction to work out what what
standard format should go to work hmm I
could I could choose a substitution
couldn't I what would you choose you
could say let u equal either the
negative x plus 1 let's just try that
let's see what happens now if I want to
use this substitution right then I'm
going to need to know what do you is so
I can get rid of the DX what is it it's
negative even negative x and now we have
a problem this is a problem right
because this is nowhere in here right at
least not yet right so I can't this is
not a suitable substitution substitution
was a good idea though what else can we
try yeah I'm going to need to multiply
by st. but the question is what and why
okay what I see here is that I mean I
know this is really obvious but it's a
fraction it's a fractured right it's a
rational function of some kind okay now
when I see fractions what kinds of
integrins right so what do I get at the
end I'll try to integrate a fraction for
instance he's a fraction right you know
what that is if you integrate that
you'll get a log Y true right but you
only get a log because this guy has a
special relationship to this guy namely
its the derivative right now this does
not look like the derivative of this to
me but we can make it we can we can
because EDX is special and cool I know
what this
okay we're going to multiply by
something okay now Elian would you like
to give a suggestion e to the X let's
multiply by e to the X on e to the X
okay what will happen okay so here's my
original okay AVX is special because
when you multiply it through what are
you going to get on your humor it up
even the X index loss what's going to
happen to these two one and then you've
got an e to the X on the bottom and
there's my F dash on F they go there's
the Lord okay now that I don't think
that is at all obvious from here unless
you've done this exact question for you
lads eNOS okay um but when you look at
this into the earth it doesn't go in a
helpful direction and it's a fraction
that kind of gives you a signal okay
right in some of the room so we decided
this substitution was bogus get rid of
here we said it was a log function right
so this is time equals log of such UK
with that that's a bit naughty sorry
I'll fix it up in retrospect there you
go okay um what I do in this constant I
care about tuition see this song little
information right that you're like well
I don't know anywhere else to go so I've
got a tea and I've got next when T
equals 0 x equals 0 that's where I begin
at the origin okay so let's give it a
well 0 equals log of 1 plus a 0 plus my
constant mm-hmm what's this going to be
this is just log 2 i'll kick remember
the other side of might as well negative
log 2 okay i could write them as laura
half but as you see the second is not
that much point I'm going to bring my
closet back into my time
equation my name is Lori ok now let's
just pause you have to do this at the
end of every major stage like oh cool i
finished the integration where am i
headed again what am i heading toward I
need X as a function of time so all I
need to do here is change the subject
that's it I think we've done most of the
legwork ok so what can I do here that
will make it easier to tease out X on
its own I've got some I've got some log
laws I can take advantage of here right
namely when you subtract logs that means
division yeah so you've got 1 plus e to
the X divided by 2 that's what that nice
means okay that's time ok suggestions
write it as an industrial equation
because it's a large measure right now
so I'll go feed the parity equals yes ok
let's shuffle
minus one okay now what I'm almost there
take logs you have to of course because
we undid the logs right so you've got to
go back you've got to go back where you
got here x equals log off full stop okay
that's a fair bit of work that's why
this is a last question entire question
okay but i think the bottlenecks are
kind of like well let's see can you
remember can you remember how to use
this thing okay can you make sure that
you're careful at evaluating your
constants and then i think the other
hard part was here dealing with this
verse think an integral okay but now
that you've seen it they won't be so
girls next time okay